comme on le sait donner un look pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé à le gêner des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
mais
sa ville et créer des livres
est ce assez c'était un peu votre code
secret votre ambition secrète quand on
est actrice à un moment donné il faut
faire autre chose il faut prendre la
parole
il faut dire que je et comment mieux
qu'en écrivant votre livre raconte
l'histoire donc de vania vassia et de
leur fille sonia by sonia c'est un peu
vous aurez pu êtes-vous je voulais que
ce soit très passionnant et je voulais
en même temps faire un examen une espèce
de bilan de ce que j'avais vécu le passé
c'est comme une boucle ça peut aussi
être un réservoir pour des données
d'avenir vous êtes un marqueur de
l'immigration heureuse que par vous êtes
à bien cette réforme n'est d'accord
qu'est ce qui vous a sauvé
qu'est ce qui vous a boosté écoutez
c'est la curiosité c'est quand même ça
la france c'est que c'est un tremplin
pour ceux qui veulent réussir
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission émission une
fois de plus consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus en france à voici les titres
de l'actualité en france 7730 cas
confirmés de coronavirus 175 décès et de
1275 personnes hospitalisées selon les
derniers chiffres le pays qui vit son
premier jour de confinement un seul mot
d'ordre
restez chez vous pour sauver des vies il
y en a pour 15 jours minimum
une attestation est désormais nécessaire
pour justifier de ses déplacements et
les forces de l'ordre sont déployées
pour y veiller
l' oms elle appelle quand elle les pays
européens à prendre les mesures les plus
audacieuses pour lutter contre la
pandémie et le confinement qui porterait
ses fruits en italie selon les bilans
bilan la courbe de progression du kovy
1900 se ralentir mais l'italie n'a pas
encore atteint le pic de contagion
averti son premier ministre
en espagne le gouvernement prévient que
le confinement de la population risque
de durer à l'échelle européenne sommet
extraordinaire de l'ue eux par
visioconférence aujourd'hui et dans le
monde les états d'urgence ou de
catastrophes sont décrétés un peu
partout les frontières se ferment les
unes après les autres
donald trump lui revendiquer à sa
formule d'un jeu site virus chinois
s'attirant les foudres de pékin et
milite pour un plan de relance de 850
milliards de dollars afin de soutenir
l'économie américaine
[Musique]
conséquence de cette crise du
coronavirus l'économie mondiale est en
chute libre bruno le maire a annoncé une
aide de 45 milliards d'euros pour les
entreprises et des salariés selon
ministre de l'économie la france va
plonger dans la récession en 2020
l'hexagone qui pourrait recourir à des
nationalisations si nécessaire toujours
selon bruno le maire
[Musique]
l'épidémie de coronavirus a déjà fait
plus de 7000 morts dans le monde et
continue donc de se propager
elle a réussi de son côté affirme avoir
pu contenir cette propagation de maj du
virus
c'est ce qu'a déclaré vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui lors d'une réunion du
gouvernement
114 cas de corona virus ont été recensés
sans aucun décès selon des chiffres
officiels et coûté 0 grâce à des mesures
opérationnelles prise à l'avancé tant au
niveau régional qu'au niveau fédéral
dès les premières semaines de l'épidémie
dans le monde nous avons pu contenir la
propagation d'une arrivée massive de la
maladie dans notre pays en ce qui
concerne le système de test qui pour le
diagnostic opérationnelle du coronavirus
signer des vaccins pour sa prévention
ce travail est effectué de manière
intensive dans nos principaux
laboratoires
la russie dispose de toutes les
compétences nécessaires dans ce domaine
et d'une base scientifique pour résoudre
ce problème dans un avenir proche on a
donc appelé les russes à faire preuve de
solidarité et de discipline et à
respecter notamment les règles de
confinement notamment pour ceux qui
rentrent de l'étranger oleg schomer
présentatrice présentateur de
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france de
nationalité russe fait partie
précisément de ces confiné qui viennent
de france nous sommes en direct avec lui
depuis moscou bon soir oleg merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france plaisir de vous
voir un petit peu loin quelle est votre
situation aujourd'hui
bonsoir écouter aujourd'hui cela fait
neuf jours dixième jour de mon
confinement à moscou je suis rentrée le
8 mars de paris est
je me suis placé en auto isolement ça
s'appelle comme ça c'est selon un décret
qui a été émis par le maire de moscou
alors tous les gens qui rentrent des
pays où le cor n'avait rue se propage
très rapidement des pays à risque et la
france en fait partie
doivent une fois rentré sur le
territoire russe appeler un numéro
d'urgence de la mairie de moscou et être
placé en confinement
c'est en confinement volontaire mais
c'est obligatoire c'est selon les termes
de ce décret alors cela salure 14 jours
vous avez aussi la possibilité de
demander un arrêt maladie c'est une
liste feuille on vous livre sur place à
la porte que vous devez obligatoirement
par la suite présenter à votre votre
travail
alors en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne les mesures que prend la russie
aujourd'hui ce sont ce ne sont pas des
mesures aussi drastiques qu'on le
croyait qu'on le croyait parce que des
rumeurs courent et aujourd'hui dans les
informations comme quoi le gouvernement
allait prendre des mesures drastiques
alors placé tout le pays en quarantaine
confinement quasi totale donc on parlait
de l'arrêt progressif du métro des
transports en commun des écoles des
universités des crèches etc
alors finalement tout ça n'a pas été
fait pourtant quelque chose a été
quelque chose a été quand même entrepris
alors il ya il ya des interdictions de
rassemblements de plus de 50 personnes
partout où qu'on soit en russie
aujourd'hui
d'autre part les écoles les crèches les
universités sont on appelle ça des ailes
sont pas fermées mais ce sont ce sont
ceux ci dessus facultative alors les
parents à envoyer leurs enfants dans les
crèches ou ne pas le faire c'est c'est
au gré des parents de décider si leurs
enfants vont aller vont aller à l'école
non alors le président russe a vivement
qu'on sait aujourd'hui de ne pas céder à
la panique de ne pas créer d'agitation
dans les grandes surfaces dans les
supermarchés super marché pourtant il a
bien dit que les mesures prises par les
pays européens comme la france
l'allemagne ou encore l'italie ou
l'espagne sont des mesures justifiées
mais pas justifier encore aujourd'hui en
russie selon le président russe
alors vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des
tests en ce qui concerne les tests il a
ajouté qu' aujourd'hui la russie serait
peut-être le premier pays à faire des
tests portatif en collaboration avec le
japon alors cette collaboration est
financée aujourd'hui par l'état russe et
les résultats selon vladimir poutine
doivent doivent avoir lieu dans les
prochains mois
on verra ça alors le gris le risque est
grand aujourd'hui en russie de
propagation de ce virus mais tout est
sous contrôle selon le président russe
les mesures ont été prises à temps pour
contrer l'épidémie c'est ce qu'affirme
le président et l'épidémie de
coronavirus je cite ne porte pas de
caractère de masse
aujourd'hui on reporte aujourd'hui
exactement 114 cas selon les données
officielles dont 106 patients qui se
sont à peu près correctement alors
l'épidémie selon toujours les sources
officielles ne présentent aucun symptôme
grave chez eux alors apparemment selon
aussi des rumeurs qui courent un peu
dans la presse ce soir à partir du 21
mars donc dans quelques jours d'ici
quatre jours
ces mesures doivent devenir plus
strictes et finalement on passerait on
passerait à une quarantaine généralisée
pour les écoles et les musiques et les
universités c'est tout ce qu'on sait à
peu près aujourd'hui il ya aussi autre
chose
aujourd'hui on sait ce dont manque à
amos cours principalement
ce sont les tests alors pourquoi parce
que il y a une obligation de certifier
ces tests sur le coronavirus que gts ne
passe pas par exemple les tests les
tests chinois ou les tests européens la
russie ne peut pas les importer parce
que non pas de certification spéciale
sur une loi c'est une loi qui pourrait
aussi selon certaines rumeurs être être
abrogée dans les temps qui viennent
parce qu'on manque sérieusement de deux
de test il ya qu un seul laboratoire
aujourd'hui qui les fabriquent etc on
est un peu en pénurie de test pour pour
le port d'un virus
donc voila un petit peu voilà un petit
peu ce qui se passe alors c'est vrai que
les mesures sont ressemble de très loin
à ceux entrepris aujourd'hui en france
mais mais on s'attend on s'attend au
pire à vrai dire on s'attend au pire
merci aux legs chômeurs présentateur de
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france
actuellement confiné à moscou a bientot
les gars prenez soin de vous merci à
vous et en france premiers jours de
confinement là encore depuis midi plus
personne n'a le droit de sortir sans
attestation et ce pour une durée de 15
jours
au total 7730 cas confirmés et 2575
personnes hospitalisées 175 décès selon
un tout dernier bilan
une des régions les plus touchées
évidemment l'alsace avec le haut rhin
une première évacuation sanitaire
militaire de malades du coronavirus
entre mulhouse et où l'eau est prévue
pour demain
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec à jean rottner président de la
région grand est également médecin
urgentiste bonsoir jean rottner merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on imagine que c'est un soulagement ce
premier transfert demain pour des
malades mulhousien ouais je dirais pas
que c'est un soulagement c'est
simplement l'engagement de la promesse
du président de la république
venir en aide de manière plus spécifique
au territoire du grand est et l estia
tout particulièrement puisque nos
réanimation sous tension extrêmement
extrêmement fortes vécues
aujourd'hui non disponibilité en lice
sur le territoire mulhousien ce qui a
obligé aujourd'hui toute une noria
d'hélicoptères à évacuer neuf patients
vers des hôpitaux de la région éloignée
et demain effectivement un procédé assez
de premières évacuations militaires dans
le cadre de ce qu'on appelle l'opération
morphée qui bénéficie de moyens aériens
spécialisé pouvoir transforme
transporter des patients réanimer intubé
et qui seront hospitalisés à l'hôpital
militaire de toulon c'est une forme de
soulagement c'est je crois de
reconnaissance en tout cas et c'est vécu
comme cela par le personnel hospitalier
de mulhouse qui considèrent qu'ils ne
sont pas oublier qu'il n'est pas oublier
que le président le gouvernement a bien
compris que ici nous étions
véritablement dans l'épidémie que les
morts sont présents que le nombre de
personnes infectées arrivants l'hôpital
dans des situations compliquées voire
grave
et bien c'est le quotidien que c'est un
personnel qui s'épuise petit à petit
parce que confrontés au stress
confrontée à la peur légitime de cette
maladie confronté à la mort bien cette
organisation que nous avons mises en
place l'arrivée prochaine de tran thi
dung animations également dans un
hôpital de campagne militaire bien bon
permettre de libérer un peu la pression
et à nos équipes de se sentir considérés
je crois que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important moi j'ai senti
dans les voix au téléphone est bien de
nouveau ou une nouvelle capacité de se
battre et d'apporter là aussi un service
public de qualité aux à l'ensemble des
habitants haut-rhinois jean renard on
vous a entendu sur plusieurs médias on
sait que la situation extrêmement
difficile dans les hôpitaux
mulhousien combien de malades atteints
du coronavirus sont admis chaque jour à
mulhouse
qu'est ce que je vais vous dire c'est
que à l'échelle de la région en
l'échelle de la région dans un avion 212
en réanimation ça vous donne là aussi
l'année la l'ampleur un peu du phénomène
ce sont souvent des patients jeunes
c'est vrai il ya aussi des patients plus
âgés
il y en a aujourd'hui 124 à l'échelle de
la région qui sont également sortis de
l'hôpital
on parle très souvent des malades qui
vont mal c'est aussi bien de parler des
malades qui vaut mieux qu'ils sont en
capacité de rentrer chez eux et c'est ça
devient petit à petit le quotidien c'est
aussi la vie qui reprend si la réussite
d'une médecine c'est des équipes qui se
battent et qui gagne pour permettre à
leurs patients de s'en sortir
ça c'est des belles histoires qu'il faut
aussi savoir raconter est ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que pour diminuer la charge
sur les hôpitaux pour diminuer
justement cette pression sur nos équipes
de santé il n'y a qu'une solution c'est
le confinement
c'est le respect des mesures de
prévention le lavage des mains les
distances à terre personnel c'est comme
ça qu'on arrivera à vaincre cette
épidémie c'est comme ça peut-être
qu'elle s'étendra un petit peu moins au
niveau national et je crois que nous
sommes tous responsables nous sommes
tous citoyens nous avons tous un devoir
finalement de préserver la vie de ceux
qui nous sont proches ou de ce que nous
sommes éventuellement appelé à croiser
ces gestes se sont essentiels ils sont
primordiaux ils sont primordiaux aussi
pour permettre aux services de soins
demain après-demain de ne pas être
surchargés et de toujours savoir
répondre de manière très qualitative aux
attentes des français
hier effectivement emmanuel macron a
fait des annonces en ce sens un
confinement compensé selon des rumeurs
très persistantes tout au long de la
journée d'hier total finalement c'est un
confinement un vrai confinement mais
avec quand même plusieurs ex pros nous
exception pardon est ce que c'était ce
que vous attendiez s'avoue satisfait
écoutez en tout cas j'ai pu constater
moi je me suis appliqué à moi-même cet
après midi j'ai travaillé ici j'avais
des réunions par téléphone ou par par
visio je crois que c'est il faut être
exemplaire et il faut qu'on s'applique à
soi-même l'ensemble de ces mesures
décidées par le gouvernement
en tout cas j'ai pu constater dans ma
ville que effectivement ce ces mesures
de confinement il était quand même très
bien respecté les premiers contrôles de
police ont eu lieu parfois jugé excessif
par certains bijoux eu lieu ça montre
que la france organisé en petit à petit
conscience de l'ampleur des dégâts
potentiels s'il ne fait pas attention et
si elle ne prend pas garde justement à
ces mesures de prévention il va falloir
tenir dans le temps ça ne va pas être
simple ça va paralyser une partie de
notre économie nous savons nous avons
d'ailleurs réfléchi tous les présidents
de région cet après-midi dans une
conférence téléphonique au tour du
premier ministre de ministre d'économie
du ministre du travail pour savoir
quelles étaient les mesures que nous
pouvions prendre en urgence pour venir
en aide aux commerçants pour venir en
aide aux entreprises aux pme start up
aux grandes entreprises a aussi aux
filières la filière automobile qu'il est
extrêmement importante dans ma région
bien tout cela se prépare nous préparons
déjà la praye épidémie parce que la pub
à devoir reprendre parce qu'il va
falloir être plus compétitif que jamais
parce que les modèles vont devoir
changer aussi
on ne peut plus forcément dépendre de
modèles qui ont vécu aujourd'hui
d'apporter à sion pour que nos
productions puisse se faire il faut
peut-être réinventer là aussi un modèle
européen est un modèle français
industriels et de production locale ma
dernière question s'adresse plutôt aux
médecins que vous êtes également à
l'urgentiste oms selon elle disait que
c'est confinement ces mesures de
confinement assez strict permettrait de
ralentir l'épidémie mais pas
nécessairement de la faire disparaître
vous pour vous quelle est la solution
justement pour éradiquer cette épidémie
et sortir de ce cauchemar pour pour
chaque français pour le monde entier en
ce moment je pense que je serai même
aller plus loin dans les mesures de
confinement
certains revendiquent moi je moi je
l'assumé en tout cas je crois c'est
solution aujourd'hui cv on est ici au
coeur de l'épidémie on voit ce que ça
donne
on voit parfois les angoisses aussi que
ces génère se retrouver en famille avoir
un temps là aussi plus personnel ça
permet d'arrêter parfois de comme on dit
de psychoter il faut que cette épidémie
s'arrête il faut qu'on leur a menti
encore une fois nous sommes toutes et
tous responsables donc je me couche je
crois véritablement à ce confinement on
voit quitter lille est premier effet
voix en espagne de là aussi que les
choses petit à petit change alors c'est
ses deux plus petites choses mais vous
savez on peut plus accepter comme ça
nous est arrivé au cours du week end 11
morts en trois jours
rien qu'à l'échelle de notre département
vous imaginez les chaînes françaises
n'ont donc nous sommes encore une fois
tout est tous responsables merci
beaucoup jean rottner président de la
région grand est médecin urgentiste
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on vous le disait donc les
français qui ont vécu leur premier jour
de confinement la france qui a pris les
mesures les plus drastiques d'europe
selon christophe castaner il invite les
français à rester chez eux pour je cite
sauver des vies interdiction de sortir
de chez soi pendant 15 jours sans
autorisation écrite de l'employeur ou
déclaration sur l'honneur pour parler de
ce premier jour de confinement à paris
notamment
notre reporter et celle fage et celle
vous vous trouvez précisément au
trocadéro en face de la tour eiffel un
quartier habituellement très peuplée est
ce que les parisiens respecte ces
mesures de confinement
oui c'est fanny les parisiens respectent
les mesures de confinement est justement
vous allez pouvoir le voir sur ces
images de nicolas couper cette place du
trocadéro il n'y a quasiment plus aucune
circulation les bars et restaurants sont
fermés et cela depuis jeudi soir et puis
on va vous montrer
pariscience trouve à quelques centaines
de mètres de la tour eiffel ans et vous
le voyez c'est une image assez
inhabituelle en puisque ce cette place
du trocadéro est totalement vide il faut
dire que depuis ce mardi midi pour les
déplacements ont été un réduit au strict
nécessaire pour vous déplacer il vous
faut remplir cette attestation sur
l'honneur téléchargeable sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur seuls les
déplacements pour des motifs
professionnels pour aller chez le
médecin pour aller au supermarché ou
encore pour promener son chien sont
autorisés alors ici la plupart des gens
à qui tu nous avons parlé ont respecté
ces mesures je vous propose de les
écouter
la première fois vous vous dites aussi
j'avais autant pour rester à la maison
je voudrais tranquilliser houston est en
réalité quand vous restez chez vous
c'est difficile donc je pense que si on
doit rester enfermé pendant plusieurs
semaines ça va être très dur
du coup on habite à fabas il faut sortir
un peu quand il faudra pas d'espoir
parce que moi je suis un sportif alors
un moment il faut s'assurer en plus bas
non je comptais me personne et je
resterai à parce que je suis celle non
non je respecte les consignes
franchement là je commence à fait deux
approches comme ça m'inquiète
sérieusement parce que là on commence à
voir vraiment il ya des cas qui commença
comment ça
comment dire les chiffres et quand ça
comptait encore assez compliqué après je
pense que l'état ils ont pris les musées
un peu tardive mais derrière quand il a
il a pris la première fois 2007 il
faudrait faire un discours est de
s'adresser au peuple français mais
l'aurait dû appliquer les règles qu'il a
vécu hier des premiers dès le premier
discours alors vu qu'il ya les touristes
ici bas je lui ai fait visiter un peu et
on profite un peu du fait qu'ils aient
personnes pour sortir c'est malgré le
corps n'en sent plus en sécurité
personnellement après je sais que j'ai
une constitution plutôt solide donc j'ai
pas trop peur du corona mais j'ai peur
de le refiler à ma famille
et pour faire respecter un ces mesures
de confinement il y a bien évidemment
est les forces de l'ordre elles sont à
présent vous allez pouvoir le voir cette
patrouille alors on a vu à plusieurs
policiers à se rendre auprès de passants
pour leur demander ce qu'il faisait
dehors nous avons nous-mêmes était
contrôlé je vous rappelle que cent mille
policiers et gendarmes sont mobilisés
dans toute la france pour faire
respecter ces mesures de confinement
merci et self argent direct du trocadéro
à paris pour faire justement respecter
ces mesures relèvent et 10 100 1000
membres des forces de l'ordre sont
mobilisées à travers tout le pays pour
en parler nous sommes avec bertrand
soubelet ancien général de corps d'armée
numéro trois de la gendarmerie nationale
bonsoir bertrand soubelet merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
qu'elle va être précisément le rôle de
l'armée dans ses mesures de confinement
au pour l'instant larvée va continuer
d'accompagner les forces de l'ordre
comme elle l'a fait jusqu'à présent dans
l'opération sentinelle c'est l'essentiel
de leurs missions pour l'instant vous
avez noté que dans l'est de la france
le service de santé des armées s'est
déployée à déployer à l'hôpital de
campagne et c'est probablement la plus
forte action désarmé au service de nos
concitoyens
pour ce qui concerne les contrôles ils
vont être faits comme ils le sont
habituellement par les forces de l'ordre
les policiers en zone urbaine et les
gendarmes dans le reste du pays et et
selon des modalités qui ont été définis
et qui sont pour l'instant gelé dire
plutôt souple parce que il faut un petit
temps d'adaptation et qui ensuite le
premier ministre a déjà indiqué ça sera
un tout petit peu plus un peu plus
compliqué et les gens seront davantage
confiné et il faudra qu'il ait
effectivement qu'ils sont porteurs de
cette attestation voir circulez vous
voulez peut-être de nous révéler un
élément important
le premier ministre semble dire
effectivement que y'aura confinement
plus important non il sera plus
important il simplement
et il demande à ce que les les consignes
qui ont été données jusqu'ici ce soit
appliquée le plus le plus précisément
possible par l'ensemble des français
je pense qu'un effet on ne pourra
ralentir la propagation du virus que si
chacun d'entre nous se conforme
strictement aux consignes qui ont été
données par le gouvernement
ces derniers jours aujourd'hui donc
premiers jours de confinement est ce que
les français d'après vos remontées du
terrain semble avoir joué le jeu est ce
qu'ils ont pris la mesure effectivement
de la gravité de la situation ce qu'ils
étaient on l'a beaucoup commenté
évidemment pas beaucoup le cas le
week-end dernier
oui des éléments dont dispose ce soir
déjà ce l'ensemble du territoire
national
dans les villes comme dans le reste du
pays les français ont impliqué les
consignes et semble désormais réaliser
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
qui est une situation extrêmement grave
ce plan sanitaire
quoique jusqu'à présent beaucoup de
personnes ont cru que ça allait être
comme une grippe habituelle que nous
connaissons à chaque année eh bien non
c'est une crise sanitaire extrêmement
grave et qui nécessite de la discipline
individuelle chaque jour et pour au
moins pour les 15 prochains jours qui
s'annoncent alors vous l'avez mentionné
un l'intervention évidemment de l'armée
en alsace on retenir nous en parler
effectivement il ya quelques instants
aussi comment se montrent un hôpital de
campagne par l'armée c'est une chose
aisée c'est quelque chose qui est voilà
comment dirais-je très codifié chez vous
parce qu'on imagine ne sait pas tout les
jours forcément avait goûté vous savez
le service de santé des armées et d'un
service qui fonctionne 365 jours par an
vous avez des hôpitaux de campagne qui
sont montés régulièrement au cours des
opérations extérieures que mène les
troupes françaises à l'étranger
ici en france il y a aussi des exercices
chacun sait exactement ce qu'il doit
faire et le montage de l'hôpital de
campagne était une manoeuvre
parfaitement bien organisée
chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire ça ne
pose aucune difficulté et ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est j'allais dire
improvisé c'est tout à fait c'est tout à
fait bien organiser les choses sont tout
à fait claires il n'y a aucune
difficulté un hôpital de campagne ça se
monte
j'allais dire globalement en quelques
dizaines d'autres
est ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura
d'autres hôpitaux de campagne destinée
est remonté en france en tout cas je
sais qu'il ya une capacité de monter des
hôpitaux de campagne
il ne se
si les nécessités de la crise sanitaire
les pose ici ou là pour l'instant
manifestement il n'en est pas question
mais chacun se tient prêt afin de
répondre aux exigences de cette crise
sanitaire qui pourrait frapper de
manière un peu plus importantes dans
certaines autres régions
merci beaucoup bertrand soubelet ancien
général de corps d'armée numéro trois de
la gendarmerie nationale merci à vous
donc quelques instants rester avec nous
nous reviendrons sur la crise du coroner
virus le premier ministre qui exhorte à
faire en sorte que ce combat soit gagner
loin des polémiques at il dit tout à
l'heure rester avec mounir revient dans
quelques instants
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
l'italie depuis le début de cette crise
en europe en tout cas fonctionne un peu
comme un laboratoire pour nous il faut
observer ce qui se passe là bas on va
nettement vers l'arrêt complet de
pratiquement du sport mondial
tous les clubs et tout les sports sont
pas affectés de la même façon les gros
résisteront beaucoup mieux que les
petits une fois qu'on aura des sportifs
humain qui seront contaminés comme ça a
pu être le cas dans le cyclisme
les choses qu'on encore différent qu'est
ce qu'on fera quand on aura une équipe
qui sera atteinte
entièrement ou vinci se transmettent etc
au fil du temps si ça continue le sport
valant mieux est-ce que c'est grave
non ce qui est grave c'est qu'il est
mort c'était les gens contaminés
c'est qu'ils aient des économies qui
sont susceptibles de s'effondrer le
sport n'est n'est que du sport
[Musique]
loïc et geoffroy de la tulle et sont
deux frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
en cinq mois de la vie de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu
inhabitée ils ont parcouru plus de 14
mille kilomètres motivés par ces
questions notre usage de l'eau témoins
utiles de notre lien la nature
[Musique]
vers 20h30 merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur arte france soyez les
bienvenus premier jour donc de
confinement pour la france
un bouleversement important dans la vie
des français n'est pas toujours facile
de trouver ses marques elle la volonté
affichée par le gouvernement faire
comprend les nouvelles mesures sur le
terrain et précision de lucas tueur une
image encore inimaginable il y a
quelques jours les rues de la deuxième
ville la plus touristique du monde se
vident le pays entier est confinée
depuis midi scènes de panique en
revanche dans ce supermarché en banlieue
parisienne
des centaines de personnes se
précipitent dans les rayons les appels
au calme des employés du magasin ne
semble rien y faire sur tout le
territoire ce sont cent mille policiers
et gendarmes qui sont déployés pour
contrôler les déplacements de la
population une première journée de
confinement placée sous le signe de la
pédagogie
selon le préfet de police de paris avant
de durcir le ton dès demain aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un moment de pédagogie
c'est bien normal la mesure est en place
depuis midi il faut l'expliquer à tout
un chacun
ça n'est pas très simple n'oubliez pas
vos papiers également mesdames messieurs
car nous serons amenés à faire des
contrôles d'identité et ses papiers
seront nécessaires voilà c'est de la
pédagogie
mais je crois au regard du résultat que
vous constatez d'ailleurs de vous même
il ya très peu de gens dans les rues
le confinement est une discipline
collective je sanctionnerai les cas où
la discipline collective n'est pas
respectée
me connaissez je vais les faire
comprendre assez vite si jamais les
explications pourtant parfaitement clair
du gouvernement n'était pas arrivé aux
oreilles de tous serait à rien n'est
compliqué pour nous on nous a expliqué
que les manifestations étaient très
compliqué on nous a expliqué que toute
une série de choses était épouvantable
mon travail n'est pas de lister les
problèmes mon travail trouver des
solutions je les trouvais les nouvelles
mesures sanitaires sont les plus
drastiques d'europe
selon le ministre de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui il assène un mot d'ordre
avec force
restez chez vous pour sauver des vies
derrière chaque poignée de mains chaque
biz chaque rencontre en groupe ce sont
des victimes de plus ce sont des morts
de plus alors oui mais sacrifiées sont
importants la décision est difficile
mais nous la prenons en responsabilité
il est question de vie et de mort il n'y
a pas au fond de difficultés à
comprendre cette règle au fond chacun
peut s'engager pour son pays peut
s'engager pour les autres et la règle
est simple il suffit de rester chez soi
rester chez soi dur à imaginer pour
certains habitants de la capitale où les
appartements sont souvent petit ce matin
à la gare montparnasse
il y avait encore beaucoup de départs je
vais en bretagne rejoindre ma mère qui
est tout seul et
vous allez me pose la question pourquoi
j'ai un jour de ma mère mais en fait
elle est infirmière de calais travail
auprès des patients sont affectés donc
moi je sais que j'ai pas lui apporter le
virus peut-être que la portée mais bon
bah enfin j'ai pris train ce matin et on
était quand même beaucoup et en galilée
beaucoup de monde et enfin déjà dans le
train les toutes les restrictions
annoncées
passons car on pas respecté vu qu'on est
côte à côte avec des passagers car moins
de 20 mètres
c'est chaud va devoir c'est jean collet
tout mais je pense qu'on n'a pas
vraiment trop chaud à l'actuel pouvoir
commencer à vous lire les prochains
jours quoi qu'on va vivre au jour le
jour et se posera des questions après
parce que ça devient déjà très
compliquée selon le ministre de la santé
et olivier ferrand le confinement
pourrait être levée dans une quinzaine
de jours à condition que la propagation
du virus était suffisamment enrayer sa
candidate la république en marche à la
mairie de paris a déclenché une
polémique aujourd'hui en affirmant avoir
alerté l'exécutif dès janvier sur le
risque d'une crise sanitaire qui selon
elle empêcherait par ailleurs la tenue
des municipales les 15 et 22 mars
l'ex ministre de la santé a même évoqué
une mascarade un mot qu'elle dit
regretter dans un communiqué publié
aujourd'hui
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec alexis poulain journaliste co
fondateur du monde moderne bonsoir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors tout d'abord
l'information à chaud edouard philippe
qui s'est exprimé chez nos confrères de
france 2 il faut mener ce combat loin
des polémiques vous l'avez trouvé
comment le premier ministre
ce soir j'ai trouvé extrêmement stressé
extrêmement tendue conscient de la bombe
politique qui avait lancé agnès buzyn
alors oui évidemment le message d'unité
nationale derrière le président et père
de la nation tout ça d'accord
multinationales c'est de rester chez soi
donc c'est pas trop difficile comme
guerre de rester chez soi que les gens
le fassent
la première chose éviter la propagation
du virus
la deuxième chose c'est que personne n'a
mis de côté son cerveau ni son esprit
critique ni sa façon de voir ce qui se
passe dans l'actualité est clairement
ses déclarations d'aujourd'hui
elle un scandale d'état simplement un
scandale d'état c'est à dire que on a
une ministre de la santé
consciente du danger qui alertent
l'exécutif les autorités compétentes qui
dit que les élections ne peuvent pas se
tenir et les élections se tiennent
elle parle de mascarade c'est la vérité
elle rétropédale sans doute sous la
pression
peu importe l'histoire la polémique
c'est pas une polémique
c'est exactement encore et encore une
affaire d'état l homme est celle là
pardon pardon politique thierry mariani
à la même analyse que vous en dans un
tweet
il vient de tweets est donc un premier
ministre nerveux très gêné par les
propos daniel mu en soulignant la
légèreté et l'irresponsabilité du
gouvernement un premier ministre qui
ment il affirme thierry mariani jamais
les forces politiques n'ont été
consultés sur le report des municipales
sur les présidents du sénat et de
l'assemblée nationale l'ont été vous
êtes d'accord avec cette analyse de
thierry mariani c'est grave ils accusent
le premier ministre de mentir de
mensonges c'est factuel les les forces
politiques n'ont pas été consultés sur
le report il s'agissait effectivement
d'un choix que emmanuel okon a assumé
d'ailleurs en se défaussant sur personne
en disant qu'il avait consulté les
autorités sanitaires son conseil
scientifique pour maintenir le premier
tour donc ça c'est un set ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui que les français en
soient conscients c'est un scandale
d'état
c'est à dire que ce gouvernement a menti
a minimisé la le scandale sanitaire qui
nous attend sachant que nos voisins
italiens lance l alerte que nos
soignants lance l alerte ils étaient
nombreux à dire qu'il fallait prendre au
sérieux qu'il fallait arrêter qu'il fait
les confiner le plus vite possible qu'il
fallait tester majoritairement qu'il
fallait commencer à produire des masques
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un
président qui dit qu'on est en guerre et
un régime
un pays incapable de produire des
masques pour tout le monde incapable de
produire des tests pour tout le monde
incapable de produire du gel
hydroalcoolique pour tout le monde cette
guerre sans munitions on va pas la
gagner et pas avec ces gens là
et croyez moi je crois que ce qu'a dit
agnès buzyn c'était peut-être évidemment
une piqûre d'orgueil parce qu'on l'a
envoyé au casse pipe avec ces
municipales à paris
mais c'est aussi peut-être simplement
qu'elle en a assez de mentir elle aurait
pu dire la vérité bien avant aux
français moi ce que je lui en veux
simplement elle aurait dû se taire ou
parler bien avant
évitez quand on a une telle connaissance
des choses avec son mari qui est aussi
très très en pointe sur les épidémies il
a travaillé sur ebola en afrique etc
tu imagines que on parlait dans le foyer
familial de ces affaires là qu'elle
était consciente de ce qu'était le
grenat virus et le kobe de 19
elle aurait dû parler bien avant comme
la version nicolas lourd disant je ne
travaille pas avec ces gens là le
mensonge ne me sied parra les gens qui
nous gouvernent aujourd'hui et je pense
que les français en sont totalement
conscient nous mentent ou manipulent et
sont incapables de répondre à la crise
qui qui est face à nous c'est
extrêmement grave
oui vous vous dites mensonges de la part
du gouvernement mais quel était
l'intérêt en l'espèce de mentir
notamment pour le premier ministre sur
la gravité de cette crise l'intérêt
c'était un choix simplement idéologique
c'est le choix qu'ils avaient fait boris
johnson en grande bretagne c'était de
dire vous savez cette épidémie en
écoutant un comité scientifique et les
scientifiques étaient partagés par
rapport à ce qu était la viralité et la
dangerosité de ce virus de dire c'est
pas grave si beaucoup de gens l'ont
parce que ce sera et énormément bénin
pour beaucoup de gens et puis on se rend
compte que non c'est pas très bénin et
puis que le système de santé est
incapable d'absorber le nombre de
malades qui seront en détresse
respiratoire et et à ce moment là on
change complètement de deux jambes c'est
ce que fait boris johnson en ce moment
mais le choix premier qui est celui de
ce gouvernement c'est de dire nous on va
faire le choix de la contamination
en dix ans les gens sont vont s'en
sortir vous aviez des analystes
politiques sur les plateaux comme
christophe barbier qui disait c'est pas
grave il y aura des morts
mais c'est normal dans toutes les crises
il ya des morts voilà voilà la réalité
le choix était chez était un choix un
comptable rationnelle de tuer des gens
de perdre des vies parce que finalement
la vie compte passer les chiffres
d'abord qui compte alors on se réveille
très tard on se paye très tard je suis
heureux qu'on en appelle à l'armée pour
monter des hôpitaux militaires dans le
grand est où là la situation est en
train d'exploser mais on aurait pu
peut-être avoir des mesures de
confinement
dès qu'on savait que la situation
dégénérait dans le grand test notamment
dans les posteurs comme il les appelait
au début pour avoir davantage de
confinement ils l'ont fait les écoles
excellent mais ce n'était pas assez
aujourd'hui on arrive à cette mesure de
confinement on ne sait pas combien de
temps ça va durer
j'en appelle à la responsabilité
personnelle de tous les français de
respecter les règles bien entendu il
faut rester chez soi bien entendu il
faut
obéir aux consignes sanitaires mais nous
ne sommes pas dû les comptes ont les
réglera quand tout ça sera fini
le jour d'après croyez moi il y aura des
comptes à rendre est ce qu a dit agnès
buzyn aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que le
premier ministre était si mal en point
et si stressée devant les caméras de
france 2 c'est simplement la vérité
c'est qu'ils savaient et qu'ils n'ont
rien c'est alors certains vous lirez
peut-être que l'épidémie change tous les
jours et que les gouvernements partout
dans le monde essaye de prendre des
mesures au fil du temps c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron lui même le 6 mars se
rend courage et les français à continuer
à vivre normalement aller dans les bars
les théâtres vous ne croyez pas du tout
le gouvernement de bonne foi sans ce
coup là si il est de bonne foi dans son
incapacité
c'est à dire que il a écouté les
mauvaises source il a fait les mauvais
choix ils gouverner c'est faire des
choix gouverner c'est prévoir
c'est qu'à un moment où il aurait
peut-être fallu faire des choix plus
drastiques sachant que c'est pas comme
si on ne pouvait pas prévoir cette crise
quand il voit philippe dit écoutez il ya
la loi on ne peut pas annuler les
élections la veille mais bien sûr que
non mais on pouvait les annuler trois
jours quatre jours avant on pouvait tout
à fait avec le parlement avec tout le
monde se mette d'accord consulter les
différents partis et les annuler les
choix qui ont été faits par les gens qui
nous gouvernent ont été les mauvais et
ça il va falloir qu'ils assument leurs
mauvais choix et leurs mauvais choix
vont être criminel parce que aujourd'hui
la crise sanitaire
elle est à nos portes elle est ici on la
vit et et il va pas falloir se défausser
sur le comité scientifique c'est eux qui
font les choix
le responsable mais pas coupable de
georgina dufoix il n'a plus lieu d'être
le sang contaminé et c'est ça n'a plus
lieu d'être aujourd'hui les responsables
au pouvoir auront des comptes à rendre
merci beaucoup à l'équipe ouvert
journaliste co fondateur du monde
moderne d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france en espagne l'épidémie
continue là bas aussi de gagner du
terrain près de
deux mille nouveaux cas de co reviennent
à virus ont été recensés
182 personnes sont décédées en 24 heures
selon un dernier bilan des autorités
elle pour aider les entreprises madrid 1
va garantir jusqu'à 100 milliards
d'euros de prêts en soit xavier lambert
des policiers munis de masques et de
gilet fluo enchaîne les contrôles des
véhicules qui se présentent à la
frontière de la jonquera au compte
gouttes
ils laissent passer les véhicules qui
présente les conditions pour rentrer en
espagne
ces nouvelles mesures font suite à la
décision de madrid de restreindre
l'accès au territoire espagnol pour
contenir la propagation du coronavirus
seuls les ressortissants nationaux les
résidents permanents et les personnes
travaillant dans la zone frontalière
sont autorisés à rentrer des mesures qui
pourraient perdurer selon les autorités
mondiales hier comme je les dis nous
devons être conscients que cela va durer
au moins quelques jours nous sommes en
confinement donc au moins dix ou onze
jours de plus et nous ne savons pas si
cela durera plus longtemps encore il est
important de maintenir la pression
nous devons trouver des moyens durant
cette période difficile
de toute façon cette patience est la
meilleure des façons de gérer la crise
pour tout le monde
dans ce contexte de plus en plus de
touristes tentent de quitter l'espagne à
l'aéroport de malaga nombreux sont ceux
qui se disent avant tout déçu de ne pas
pouvoir profiter de leurs vacances
il n'y a rien les clubs de golf sont
fermés les restaurants fermés
tout est fermé et on nous a dit de ne
pas sortir sauf si c'était nécessaire
donc nous avons fait ce qu'on nous a dit
nous sommes restés enfermés jusqu'à
venir à l'aéroport et nous y sommes nous
sommes venus ici
pour des vacances cd censé être un mois
ici est ensuite allé au portugal pendant
un mois et à cause du corona virus notre
gouvernement dans un suggéré de rentrer
chez nous nous essayons d'aller à madrid
ce soir puis nous sommes censés aller à
londres et de londres à toronto
l'espagne est depuis samedi placées en
état d' alerte tout comme en france les
habitants sont confinés chez eux sauf
pour se rendre au travail à la pharmacie
ou pour faire des courses alimentaires
et pour parler de cette situation en
espagne nous sommes avec erwan arrosé
dorado journalistes espagnols bonsoir
honneur aux et merci dorado merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france après
l'italie et l'espagne donc la france est
passée elle aussi au confinement depuis
ce midi déjà quel est votre ressenti en
tant que journaliste espagnol à paris
déjà la première des choses c'est
qu'effectivement les espagnols se sont
étonné des déclarations du pot du
président de la république jeudi soir
quand il n'a pas décrété le confinement
quand il y a il a fallu attendre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à midi pour que ce
confinement soit soit à instaurer on
sait que l'espagne a sur ce plan au
moins entre 48 72 heures d'avancé par
rapport à à la france et nous on voit
aujourd'hui en espagne peg les derniers
chiffres vous en avez donné et quelques
zine par rapport aux gens qui sont
contaminés par rapports aux gens qui
sont décédés et en espagne on voit que
ce confinement aurait dû être décrétée
avant ça a été le cas en italie on a
regardé bizarrement ce qu'il faisait
l'italie on l'a pas prise au sérieuse et
enfin quand on se rendent compte
aujourd'hui et les italiens avaient
raison que c'est eux qui avaient pris
les mesures avant tout le monde et même
comme ça ils n'ont pas évité
qu'aujourd'hui des plus de 2000 morts
comment vous vous l'expliquer on avec
edouard philippe s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure il ya déjà pas mal de critiques
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux on a
vu un tweet de l'homme politique thierry
mariani qui expliquait que le premier
ministre était gêné vous c'est quoi
votre regard là-dessus c'est que le
gouvernement a sous-évalué à la crise a
menti peut-être pour des raisons voilà
qu'on qui nous échappe ici quelle est
votre analyse sous-évalué forcément
certainement la preuve et l'état
aujourd'hui on est obligé à être confiné
il a fallu que le président de la
république quand on a en l'espace d'à
peine 4 et surprennent deux fois là la
parole pour décréter ce qu'il aurait dû
faire et jeudi dernier il est certain d
n'est pas n'est pas vouloir annuler le
premier à tulle le premier tour des
élections a beaucoup joué pour que se
confine confinement ne soit pas à
instaurer en france avant ses critiques
par rapport au gouvernement en france
ç'a eu aussi en espagne où on accuse le
gouvernement espagnol aussi à un moment
donné d'avoir tardé à apprendre les
premières mesures mais il est certain
qu'en france quand on le regarde
l'actualité française puisque ce premier
tour des élections est né pas avoir
voulu le l'annuler et le responsable
entre guillemets de ce retard de
confinement le gouvernement aurait dû le
faire avant ils l'ont pas fait ba
aujourd'hui ces critiques sont normales
et ils sont sincères je pense de
beaucoup d des responsables politiques
aujourd'hui le gouvernement français est
face à une décision est mauvaise
décision qui a été prise et il commence
à payer les conséquences pour vous vous
parlez beaucoup des élections
municipales c'est l'une des raisons peut
être pour lesquels les décision aurait
été prise avec du retard
il y aurait autant de cynisme de la part
du gouvernement français
écoutez vous voyez ce qui se passait
owni tally à peine trois jours avant
l'intervention des jeudis du président
de la république
la porte parole du gouvernement a traité
avec un certain mépris les blessures qui
avait été prise par les italiens les
français ont vu aussi ce qui s'est passé
en espagne et l'espagne n'a pas renoncé
à prendre des mesures qu à partir du 9
mars
il faut juste rappeler que deux jours
avant effectivement le président sortez
allez au théâtre et invités et les
français à faire une vie normale donc on
voyait parfaitement comment ça se
passait dans les pays voisins de la
france on pouvait parfaitement
comprendre tu es les frontières ne sont
pas fermées et la crise allait la
pandémie elle est vraiment arrivé et
prendre de l'ampleur en france et suis
toujours effectivement convaincu pour
avoir parlé avec avec des responsables
politiques à un moment donné et que le
fait de ne pas avoir voulu annuler ce
premier tour des élections je ne veux
pas rentrer s'il y avait des calculs
politiques ou pas ce serait
effectivement très grave comme disait ne
l'attaquent venons juste juste avant moi
mais c'est vrai que cette décision de ne
pas annuler a forcé à l'exécutif
elle n'est pas à demander le confinement
jeudi lors de l'intervention
de président de la république parce que
s'il avait été annulée le confinement
aurait été effectivement pris beaucoup
havre beaucoup plus tôt qu'il ne l'a été
c'est à dire aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup aux rouennais rosé dorado
d'avoir été avec nous aux journalistes
espagnols à paris merci à vous on a
parlé il ya quelques instants l'italie
avec les premiers signes de
ralentissement de la propagation de
l'épidémie
la barre des 2000 décès a été franchie
mais les données de la protection civile
italienne montre un infléchissement de
la hausse encore plus nette dans les
premières régions placées en quarantaine
une première bonne nouvelle très
relative évidemment mais qui laisse donc
apparaître les effets positifs du choix
du confinement de la population
la solution doit circuler dot être un
message fort poli pays étrangers il faut
agir tôt face à ce virus afin d'éviter
comme dans notre cas d'être dépassés
jour après jour donc il s'agit de deux
vans et cela signifie créer des
structures capables de fournir une
thérapie intensive ce que nous faisons
ici cela fonctionne il faut fermer des
salles d'opération réduire les
chirurgies avant de diriger les
ressources humaines et matérielles dans
les thérapie intensive pour évoquer la
situation italienne
nous sommes en direct avec jonathan
l'eau bâti merde l'ena dans la province
de bergame bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france 3 145
décès enregistrés en italie c'est
dernières 24 heures on a eu pourtant des
moutons bonne nouvelle dans la journée
l'épidémie les coupes qui semblait un
petit peu baissé quelles sont quelle est
la situation sur place
bonsoir à tous la situation encore
aujourd'hui d'extrême urgence
on a aujourd'hui un peu plus de 2500
morts c'est vrai qu'il est numéro
o au prix de jeu deux jours et ils vont
un peu mieux mais c'est quand même
situations d'urgence qui restent à
bergame le centre de nogent c'est de
coronavirus sont toute l'italie
alors il ya eu effectivement ces mesures
de confinement très sévère chez vous un
confinement total mise en place il ya
déjà plusieurs jours est-ce qu'on
commence déjà à en voir les effets
positifs
oui mais ont sûrement il ya beaucoup de
monde qui a déchiré décidé de rester à
la maison et il dans quelques jours
j'espère déjà de demain qu'on va avoir
des effets positifs sur le nombre de
personnes qui ont été testés positifs
alors malgré cela ce n'est pas encore le
pic de l'épidémie vous quelle est la
situation dans votre village comment
vous vous organiser avec ces mesures de
confinement mis en place le 8 mars est
chez nous on a six personnes qui ont été
testés positifs ou encore un navire uss
quatre personnes qui sont
pas là car la quarantaine chez eux ils
peuvent pas sortir de maison et après
ouvrière on a vu une période une
personne qui est décédée et pas les
mesures contre ans en apprendre sur le
territoire c'est avec la sécurité civile
avec la police avec les gendarmes
on attend faire une surveillance sur le
territoire on a même on va faire les
commissions pour les familles pour les
personnes âgées perdent les personnes
qu'ils ont plus de 65 ans ont une portée
et les commissions la maison comment le
vivent les italiens est ce qu'ils sont
en accord avec ces mesures prises par le
gouvernement ou comme en france on voit
ici ou là quelques critiques
sûrement les italiens qui comprend la
situation est un peu la peur un peu les
numéros ils ont fait comprendre tout le
monde qui est c'est faux c'est l'unique
solution qu'on peut prendre en ce moment
ça va il n'y a pas des grosses
polémiques sur ça quelle est la
situation dans les hôpitaux on sait
qu'elle est et qu'elle est certainement
encore dramatique on parle voilà deux
témoignages assez poignant des médecins
qui doivent faire des choix entre
différents malades
est-ce que ça semble toujours le cas
notamment près de votre village oui
aujourd'hui il ya eu la notice que le
grand hôpital de bergame l'ospedale et
unity il peut plus recevoir des
personnes dans les soins intensifs y en
a 80 g que dans ce type d'opération est
d'à demain il va voir un deuxième
hôpital qui est mis en place par l armée
will rares 40e place d'autre que super
yam sur milan aussi il va voir un
deuxième hôpital avec 400 places en plus
qu'est ce que aujourd'hui vous attendez
du gouvernement on sait qu'en france il
y à l'armée qui
réagit qui intervient notamment dans une
de nos provinces les plus touchées pour
faire des hôpitaux de campagne est ce
que ce genre de situation de deux
solutions plus tôt et il est elle
envisageable en italie également
oui sûrement on a déjà beaucoup de
personnes qui vient de l'armée qui sont
au service dans les hôpitaux italiens à
bergame ya vingt médecins qui vient de
l'armée qui sont venir donner et soutien
aux jeunes médecins pour suivre tous les
personnes qui sont dans les soins
intensifs
un merci beaucoup à gens n'attendent au
bâti merde aliéna dans la province de
bergame en italie nous avoir apporté
votre témoignage et bon courage à vous
aussi et ce témoignage
cette fois ci dans nos journalistes
fabien riffs testé positif aux
coronavirus qu'il a développé le virus
lors d'un voyage en slovénie à la
frontière italienne précisément il se
trouve actuellement dans un chalet
réquisitionné pour accueillir des
patients étrangers contaminés alors il
ya un peu plus d'une semaine j'étais en
vacances avec un groupe d'amis l'iran
slovénie et lors du dernier jour du
séjour au moment où mes amis venaient de
partir j'ai pensé présenter des petits
symptômes légers pas très inquiétant
mais d'ordre respiratoire et quelques
maux de tête qui m'ont poussé à aller
voir le docteur et dans le contexte
actuel en fait le docteur ne reçoit pas
les docteurs slovènes ne recevait pas de
patients étrangers ce qui a fait que je
suis allé à l'hôpital où on a fini par
me faire un test du coronavirus et j'ai
appris le lendemain matin du test que
j'étais positif ce qui a fait que j'ai
passé près de cinq jours en confinement
à l'hôpital au terme de ces cinq jours
ne présentant pas de symptômes
inquiétants
j'ai donc été transféré dans ce chalet
où je suis le premier arrivé et où je
devrais recevoir de la compagnie dans
les prochains jours peut-être d'autres
patients d'autres pays qui ne peuvent
pas rentrer chez eux et qu'ils seront
confinés ici le temps d'être testés
négatifs au virus
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons toujours sur cette
crise du coronavirus qui domine
évidemment l'actualité avec ce dernier
bilan en france 7730 cas confirmés 175
décès et de 1275 personnes hospitalisées
restez avec nous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
qu'est ce que tu m'as 3 1 est pourquoi
tu m'as tu l'as toujours qu'est ce que
tu vas toi qu'est ce tu m'as alors un
vase il vient vapeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le zéro derma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents donc
des deux parents sont porteurs sains de
la maladie ce qui transmet ce qu'ils
transmettent en fait alors à leurs
enfants des enfants ne peuvent pas
s'exposer au soleil
acial comment on pourrait résumer une
journée type de votre vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut pas qu'ils
aient un millimètre de pau qui sera
exposée apporte ses gants ses vêtements
on leur met leur masque avec la visière
qui leur permet de regarder à
l'extérieur
une fois qu'ils y sont ma fille je veux
pas qu'elle ait une vie où il reste tout
le temps à la maison c'est pas une vie
tu auras la vie comme tout le monde et
ça je ferai tout pour que ça soit le cas
[Musique]
chez nous on dit dieu arranger tous les
cadeaux dans un faux et ensuite il s'est
rendu dans tous les pays du monde mais
quand à la fin il est venu au congo il
était épuisé et davy d'accord
donnons-leur ceux qui restent seconde
peau
[Musique]
ce pays est un paradis c'est pour ça que
ne comprenons pas comment est ce
possible que nous soyons toujours
pauvres dans notre pays tu penses que
dans 20 ans aura fini qu'il me faudra
encore vingt ans pour en finir avec ce
rocher bien sûr les blantyre tous les
avantages de nominer rose on a toujours
faim on fait ça pour que nos enfants ne
meurent pas de faim
est ce qu'il n'y avait pas de minéraux
du congo mon dieu mais comment
pouvons-nous re vivre dans un monde sans
téléphone sans ordinateur sans avion
pour être interpellé ce sera vraiment un
désastre east nous retournerions à la
période préhistorique vous voyez
[Musique]
idiot tous nos voitures
oui mais briques de terre comprimée
radialement renforcer et c'est ce qu'ils
sont vraiment
il ya plus de 70 maisons et environ 140
personnes qui habitent ici avec leur
famille
ça aide a donné forme possible
les rayons de soleil il pénètre et
chauffe la maison les murs absorbent la
chaleur puis la rendre
sanaa - poussent naturellement mais
comme on accumule les eaux usées ici on
utilise les plantes pour les purifier
créé ici notre propre petite oasis
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur air
france pour cette deuxième heure
d'information tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité avec la crise du
coronavirus les frontières se ferment
les unes après les autres l'entrée dans
l'union européenne est désormais
interdite pour 30 jours annonce un gala
merkel
outre atlantique donald trump lui
revendique sa formule d'un jeu site
virus chinois s'attirant les foudres de
pékin
il milite pour un plan de relance de 850
milliards de dollars afin de soutenir
l'économie américaine
[Musique]
conséquence de cette crise du
coronavirus l'économie mondiale est en
chute libre un bruno le maire a annoncé
une aide de 45 milliards d'euros pour
les entreprises et les salariés
selon le ministre de l'économie la
france va plonger dans la récession en
2020 l'hexagone qui pourrait recourir à
des nationalisations si nécessaire
toujours selon bruno le maire
[Musique]
aux etats unis malgré le coronavirus la
primaire démocrate se poursuit pour
départager tombe mal jo by dane et
bernie sanders et les bureaux de vote
ont rouvert ce matin en floride et en
illinois a malgré les craintes de la
propagation du virus le gouvernement de
l'ohio à lui fait le choix de reporter à
la dernière minute les primaires
présidentielles dans son état décision
de médias etc ce qui fit la nouvelle est
tombée quelques heures avant l'ouverture
des bureaux de vote dans l'ohio la
primaire démocrate est suspendu pour
cause de coronavirus le gouverneur de
l'état en question ne veut prendre aucun
risque face à la pandémie qui secoue les
états unis ces derniers jours nous ne
pouvons pas mener cette élection en
votant en personne pendant 13 heures et
nous devons nous conformer à ses
directives
c'est pourquoi je recommande
après m'être entretenu avec le
secrétaire d'état avec le procureur
général avec le lieutenant-gouverneur
que le vote soit prolongée jusqu'au 2
juin
aucun vote en personne n'ait lieu
aujourd'hui mais plutôt que le vote en
personne ait lieu le 2 juin
mais d'ici là que le vote par
correspondance soit autorisée pourtant
ce lundi le président donald trump avait
jugé inutile de reporter des primaires
lui qui estime également que la pandémie
pourrait prendre fin d'ici l'arrivée de
l'été il me semble que si nous faisons
un très bon travail
non seulement nous allons maintenir le
taux de mortalité à un niveau beaucoup
plus bas
mais les gens parlent de juillet août
quelque chose comme ça il se pourrait
donc que ce soit pendant cette période
où quand je dis nettoyer ça nettoie font
les autres même pas ce terme mais ça
nettoie à fond
dans cette course de la primaire
démocrate entre joe biden et bernie
sanders
tout n'est pas reporté les scrutins sont
prévus aujourd'hui dans trois autres
états notamment floride mais avec des
mesures de précaution renforcer d'autres
états comme le kentucky où la louisiane
ont d'ores et déjà repoussé l'élection
dans les prochains jours plusieurs
scrutins pourraient également être
reporté d'ici les prochaines semaines
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivier python auteur de la nouvelle
révolution américaine aux éditions plon
bonsoir olivier py merci d'être un bon
coup en direct sur rt france loyaux qui
reporte les primaires démocrates
on ne va pas comparer avec les
municipales françaises mais est-ce que
ce coronavirus risque quand même de
peser très fortement dans cette campagne
démocrate
premièrement et après peut-être dans la
présidentielle américaine
en fait on a un décalage entre ce qui se
passe en europe et en particulier en
france et ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
d'environ une quinzaine de jours on le
voit avec le nombre de cas de
contamination et le nombre de décès donc
il est assez difficile aujourd'hui de
savoir ce que dans quinze jours ou dans
trois semaines la situation aux états
unis va être ce qui est incontestable
c'est que si on se suit la tendance aux
états unis comme elles semblent se se
dérouler en europe on risque
effectivement d'avoir au moment de la
mise en place des conventions
c'est à dire à l'été les conventions
delluc démocratique par démocrate et
républicaine
on risque d'avoir à ce moment là un
certain nombre de problèmes
effectivement avec des états on l'a vu
avec l'ohio qui n'ont pas encore voté et
qui pourraient ne pas voter à ce moment
là et donc on pourrait effectivement
avoir des difficultés harcelant vous là
les américains n'ont pas encore pris la
pleine mesure de la gravité de cette
épidémie
s'ils ont pris la pleine mesure n'y a
pas eu de phénomène de 2,2 deux derniers
jours avant avant avant incarcération
comme on a eu en france ils sont rentrés
tout de suite dans le jeu del annonce de
l'état d'urgence par donald trump
alors ensuite comme c'est un état
fédéral et donc ce sont 50 états on a
des dispositifs qui sont différents
selon les états par exemple le
new-jersey est en état d'urgence avec
l'état de washington et d'autres états
ne le sont pas encore et à l'intérieur
des états certaines villes se sont mis
également en état d'urgence et le cas de
new york ou de los angeles par exemple
qui sont allés plus loin que ce qu'avait
décidé les gouverneurs de leurs états
respectifs
donc on a en tout cas une situation qui
est assez maîtrisé on a eu dans un
premier temps
un rush vers les supermarchés pour se
doter d des provisions les plus les plus
essentiels et là on retourne un petit
peu vers la normale et on a encore une
fois des disparités en fonction de
l'endroit où on habite aux états unis
alors c'est vrai que donald trump à
prayssas pardonnez moi l'expression un
petit peu par dessus la jambe
au début un il ironisé un peu sur 7 ce
qui l'est c'est un peu une grille peut
il donner des poignées de main un petit
peu facile comment les américains ont
jugé l'attitude de ce président comme
toujours avec donald trump et le
coronavirus ne fait pas exception à la
règle
c'est extrêmement clivant ses supporters
trouvent qu'il prend les bonnes
décisions ne met pas en cause
effectivement le fameux épisode de la
poignée de main lors de la conférence de
presse où justement il décrétait l'état
d'urgence
et puis les opposants effectivement
parle de négligence parle de deux
mesures de mesures qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
pour l'instant le taux de contamination
aux états unis est de l'ordre de 200
nouveaux cas par jour
et donc on est dans un trend qui est à
peu près celui de l'europe avec le
retard qui est qui est à peu près de 15
et d'une quinzaine de jours et donc les
gens attendent de savoir si les mesures
qui ont été décidées c'est-à-dire il ya
une fois des mesures d'ordre sanitaire
mais également des mesures d'ordre
économique vont être efficace aux états
unis alors donald tram qui cherche je
sais pas si l'expression et eurozoom
quand même à politiser ce virus qu'il
appelle le virus chinois oui d'ailleurs
des correspondants de presse en chine
américains ont été expulsés aujourd'hui
donc on est de toute façon toujours dans
une guerre en tout cas une guerre des
mots entre les états unis la chine donc
c'est la guerre commerciale par d'autres
moyens le corps n'a virus ne fait pas
exception à la règle
en tout cas ça permet à donald trump
d'assumer la fermeture des frontières
puisque c'est un virus étrangers entre
guillemets d'assumer le fait que des
restrictions soient opérés dans un
servante de domaine économique
et puis évidemment de démo de demander
le déblocage à l'échelon fédéral de
quelques 850 milliards de dollars en
tout cas c'est ce qui est en discussion
actuellement avec le congrès une
dernière petite question qui concerne le
traitement parce que c'est par là qu'on
va s'en sortir un premier essai clinique
d'un vaccin eu lieu justement sur 45
personnes aux états unis lundi 16 mars à
ce qu'on en parle beaucoup
outre atlantique et beaucoup d'espérance
sur ce vaccin non mais en tout cas les
américains espèrent avoir rapidement un
accès à ce vaccin et il espère
évidemment puisque c'est le patriotisme
américain qui joue que ce soit des
savants des experts des médecins
américains qui le découvre en premier
merci beaucoup olivier py ton de la
nouvelle révolution américaine aux
éditions plon d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france la lutte contre le
cannabis est aussi une guerre économique
et financière déclaration ce matin de
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
annoncé une aide de 45 milliards d'euros
pour les entreprises et des salariés
la dette française dépassera les 100 %
du pib cette année après les mesures
prises pour par l'état pour soutenir
l'économie face à cette crise toujours
selon bruno le maire la france prête à
recourir à des nationalisations si
nécessaire dans
l'actualité en écoute nous aurons en
2020 une situation de croissance
évidemment très détérioré la zone euro
sera également en récession le choc sera
violent mais l'économie européenne et
l'économie française ont toutes les
capacités à rebondir si nous prenons les
bonnes décisions et les bonnes décisions
consiste à protéger des salariés des
compétences notre force de travail nos
entreprises éviter les faillites et nous
permettre de redémarrer le plus vite
possible et la bourse de paris clôture
donc avec un rebond de 2 84 % retrouvant
donc quelques petites couleurs au
lendemain d'un gros plongeant les
bourses mondiales
toujours très fragile néanmoins hier les
dirigeants des pays du g7 se sont dits
déterminés à faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour restaurer la croissance
mondiale qui va si en raison de la
pandémie de corona binoche
une situation qui reste donc critique et
qui va de pair avec déconfinement un
massif aux répercussions à conséquences
sur l'économie et aux états unis on en
parlait tout à l'heure rebond aussi des
indices nord-américains pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis new york
avec charles or telle hauteur et
investisseurs c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir charles orthez merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france
le plan de relance de 850 milliards de
donald trump est ce que ça risque de
passer au congrès qui va être adoptée
par le congrès merci s2ma pays avec
seulement il a annoncé un plan d'urgence
afin dé mettre un terme à l'effondrement
des marchés boursiers
je pense que dans tous les partis
les gens vont s'allier à d'autres telle
est ce qu'il va à fonctionner à court et
à long terme je cet autre chose alors on
imagine que c'est le pire cauchemar de
donald trump lui qui tient évidemment
comme chaque président d'ailleurs à une
économie forte aux états unis il a
évoqué la possibilité hier d'une
récession aux états unis en pleine
campagne est ce que ça pourrait
justement peser cette crise pour lui je
pense que cette fuite mais a failli être
favorable le court terme nous sommes
encore le même jour des élections
ce ne sont pas que le régime dukan et
les démocrates qui fait aujourd'hui il
ya de plus en plus d'électeurs
indépendants qu'ils mégotent forcément
ni pour l'un ou l'autre des parties de
recours contre deux jeunes a été bannie
sanders et je pense que les républicains
a bondi en sentirez parce qu'il s'agit
de personnes
john's cible mais il ya encore beaucoup
de temps dans les élections
on le disait donc donald trump
qu'ils envisageaient une récession vous
êtes également investisseurs à ce que ce
plan de relance de 850 milliards du
président américain sait ce qu'on attend
quand on est un entrepreneur aux états
unis cela a fonctionné en 2007 2009
qu'il centrerait fini la taille du
budget gouvernemental le aux états unis
est très important que le 13 mai pickas
nous avons beaucoup de textes bien plus
aujourd'hui que que nous en avions
obtenu celle qui lorsque donald trump a
commencé et en tout cas bien que ce
qu'on mérite ce qu'il faudrait c'est
réduire la taille du gouvernement et
s'arranger autrement mais ce plan ne
fait pas cela la fed
on le sait a également un grand rôle à
jouer à la fête qui propose aux soutenir
les prêts automobiles notamment et
d'accorder des prêts aux entreprises est
une mesure suffisante
je pense que ce qu'il faut faire dans ce
pays dans tous les autres pays en europe
au japon et cetera
c'est de diminuer la dette au niveau
national régional et mondial
elle est bien trop important qui voilà
ce que nous devons faire du pouvons le
faire que la manière plus facile en la
réduisant progressivement en réduisant
nos dépenses ou en passant par des
banqueroutes nationale je pense que la
réserve fédérale peut jouer un rôle là
mais il faut coupler ses actions avec
une réforme structurelle dans notre pays
et au niveau mondial vous dites en
réduire la dette mais
et on voit tous les gouvernements y
compris en europe sont en train de
complètement changer leur stratégie
d'injecter de l'argent quitte à faire
voilà augmenté les déficits la france va
augmenter son déficit de plus de 200% du
pib est ce que c'est bien le moment de
est bien possible surtout de réduire la
dette avec cette crise terrible du
coronavirus qui pèsent sur l'économie
devront réduire la taille du
gouvernement
regardez ce qu'ont réussi à faire par
téléphone
ils n'ont pas le faire il ya plusieurs
années et la technologie a beaucoup
évolué mais le gouvernement devient plus
importante plus du complexe a dit
à court terme on peut arranger les
choses non il est certain qu'il faut
réduire le gouvernement il peut y avoir
moins de personnel moins de dépenses en
moins de personnel cela devrait être
possible avec l'évolution des
technologies
une dernière petite question qui une
information qui a attiré mon intention
de manière un peu voilà curieuse le
coronavirus qui fait exploser les ventes
d'armes aux états unis vous avez
l'explication vous je pense que c est ce
que les gens s'attendent à des mesures
afin de se désarmer de désarmer les
américains contre leur volonté par
exemple s'il nous prônons un vaccin on
peut imaginer que le gouvernement dirait
et bien sûr personnes doivent tout
réapprendre ce vaccin et les
gouvernements ou locales disent qu'ils
vont réduire les 22 gardes et projettent
même retirer les armes aux américains
nous qu'ils essayent de 200 garantir à
merci beaucoup en tout cacher leur telle
hauteur et
investisseurs d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir pour notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur et le corona virus qui
ne cesse de dépasser les frontières
l'état d'urgence a été déclaré dans
l'état de rio de janeiro et dans la
ville de sao paulo où le premier décès
lié au coronavirus a été annoncée
aujourd'hui ces dernières 48 heures les
chefs de gouvernement d'amérique latine
ont durci le ton et les mesures
drastiques mais également de solidarité
tour d'horizon avec moi lead bennani les
tons sont solennelle les mêmes postures
c'est au tour de l'amérique latine de
fermer ses portes
j'ai pris la décision de fermer toutes
les frontières les frontières terrestres
les frontières fluviales et celle que
nous avons aussi avec le venezuela qui
sont des décisions que nous avons pris
auparavant
ce mardi 17 mars à 5 heures du matin
tout le venezuela entre en quarantaine
tout le pays
les 23 et à une intervention télévisée
une présentation graphique locaux vides
19 se propage à une vitesse inquiétante
plus de dix cas par jour au venezuela
le premier a été signalé vendredi
dernier fermeture des frontières pendant
quinze jours un mois travail à la maison
imposer la distanciation social
recommandée en europes est désormais en
vigueur en amérique latine on oublie
tout genre de célébration dont les
boîtes de nuit les bars les cinémas les
événements sportifs de masse les salles
de sport les parcs à thème et les
activités nocturnes dans les centres
événementiel ans lundi le président
péruvien informé que neuf nations
touchées par le coronavirus se sont
engagés à partager des informations sur
la santé est acheté en solde du matériel
médical et des médicaments dans le but
de lutter contre cette pandémie et le
port des masques semble être une affaire
d'état
d
dieu merci la plupart des gens ont
décidé de respecter les ordres et de
rester chez eux
mais les gens qui sortent doivent porter
des protections j'ai aussi vu beaucoup
de gens utilisaient des masques très peu
de gens portent des gants
disons que 30% de la population utilise
le masque alors que le reste marche
comme si de rien n'était comme
enseignant au mexique place au masque
réutilisables
tous les moyens sont bons pour se
protéger estelle à caumont et corriente
c'est du tissu ordinaire mais qui
fonctionne un peu comme le masque
jetable
vous ne pouvez pas les comparer aux
masques chirurgicaux et mais ils peuvent
vous éviter des ennuis au pilori cobayes
et la sensibiliser l'opinion défi majeur
des gouvernements en plein été au brésil
alors que plus de 200 cas ont été
confirmés
des centaines de brésiliens continue de
se réunir ces derniers jours sur les
plages de rio ou encore pour célébrer le
président bolle sonar haut ce que les
gens font est inestimable malgré le fait
de rester à la maison
je ne peux pas les commandes et la
manifestation n'est pas la mienne si je
dis que c'est exagéré
il va y avoir des gros titres est au
fond la carte fait du bon travail
pour l'heure le faible nombre de décès
dans cette partie du globe laisse
présager que la propagation de cette
pandémie ne fait que commencer
en france premier genre de confinement
lisez depuis midi plus personne la
droite sortir sans attestation et ce
pour une durée de 15 jours
au total 7734 a confirmé 2575 personnes
hospitalisées 175 décès en france qui a
pris les mesures les plus drastiques
d'europe
selon christophe castaner il invite les
français à rester chez eux pour je cite
sauver des vies et edouard philippe de
son côté a rappelé ce soir chez nos
confrères de france 2 que seul le
respect strict des consignes permettrait
de ralentir la progression de l'épidémie
écoutez nous devons respecter ses
consignes les respecter très strictement
si nous voulons qu'elle est un effet et
cet effet que nous recherchons c'est le
ralentissement de la circulation du
virus
je ne prends pas du tout à la légère la
lourdeur de ce que nous demandons à nos
concitoyens d'ailleurs ils l'ont bien
compris je crois donc voilà les
consignes sont claires on reste chez soi
sauf dans les cinq cas qui sont
autorisés et pour vérifier que ces
consignes sont bien respectées nous
avons demandé avec le ministre de
l'intérieur aux forces de l'ordre police
gendarmerie à toutes les forces qui
concourent à la sécurité de veiller à
rappeler fermement à nos concitoyens qui
ne respecteraient pas ces règles
l'intérêt pour eux de les respecter nous
avons prévu des sanctions dans
l'hypothèse où il ne les respecteraient
pas aujourd'hui la sanction était prévu
à 38 euros
à partir de demain nous vous proposons
un projet de loi qui permettra de passer
à 135 euros d'amendé forfaitaire qui
pourra le cas échéant être majoré je le
dis d'abord en parlant à la raison et
ensuite en le en parlant à nos français
avec la possibilité d'avoir l'autorité
que m'incombe mes fonctions vous devez
rester chez vous sauf dans les cas qui
sont autorisés ils sont peu nombreux et
il faut respecter strictement les règles
et j'observe et j'observe et je me
réjouis que beaucoup de français ont
compris la nécessité
je les en remercie il faut que chacun la
comprenne et l'appliquent mes premiers
confinement un jour de confinement pour
le pays un bouleversement important dans
la vie des français n'est pas toujours
facile de trouver ses marques
la volonté affichée par le gouvernement
faire comprendre les nouvelles mesures
sur le terrain à l'instar des douars
philippa d'instants elle les précisions
le lucas tueur une image encore
inimaginable il y a quelques jours les
rues de la deuxième ville la plus
touristique du monde se vident le pays
entier est confinée depuis midi scènes
de panique en revanche dans ce
supermarché en banlieue parisienne
des centaines de personnes se
précipitent dans les rayons les appels
au calme des employés du magasin ne
semble rien y faire sur tout le
territoire ce sont cent mille policiers
et gendarmes qui sont déployés pour
contrôler les déplacements de la
population une première journée de
confinement placée sous le signe de la
pédagogie
selon le préfet de police de paris avant
de durcir le ton dès demain aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un moment de pédagogie
c'est bien normal la mesure est en place
depuis midi il faut l'expliquer à tout
un chacun
ça n'est pas très simple n'oubliez pas
vos papiers également mesdames messieurs
quarts
nous serons amenés à faire des contrôles
d'identité et ses papiers seront
nécessaires voilà c'est de la pédagogie
mais je crois au regard du résultat que
vous constatez d'ailleurs de vous même
il ya très peu de gens dans les rues
le confinement est une discipline
collective je sanctionnerai les cas où
la discipline collective n'est pas
respectée vous me connaissez je vais les
faire comprendre assez vite si jamais
les explications pourtant parfaitement
clair du gouvernement n'était pas arrivé
aux oreilles de tous serait rien n'est
compliqué pour nous on nous a expliqué
que les manifestations étaient très
compliqué on nous a expliqué que toute
une série de choses était épouvantable
mon travail n'est pas de lister les
problèmes mon travail trouver des
solutions je les trouvais les nouvelles
mesures sanitaires sont les plus
drastiques d'europe selon le ministre de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui il assène un mot
d'ordre avec force
restez chez vous pour sauver des vies
derrière chaque poignée de mains chaque
biz chaque rencontre
en gros ce sont des victimes de plus ce
sont des morts de plus alors oui mais
sacrifiées sont importants la décision
est difficile mais nous la prenons en
responsabilité il est question de vie et
de mort il n'y a pas au fond de
difficultés à comprendre cette règle on
fond chacun peut s'engager pour son pays
peut s'engager pour les autres et la
règle est simple il suffit de rester
chez soi rester chez soi dur à imaginer
pour certains habitants de la capitale
où les appartements sont souvent petit
ce matin à la gare montparnasse
il y avait encore beaucoup de départs je
vais en bretagne rejoindre ma mère qui
est tout seul et
vous allez me poser la question pourquoi
j'ai rejoint de ma mère mais en fait
elle est infirmière de calais travail
auprès des patients sont affectés donc
moi je sais que j'ai pas lui apporter le
virus peut-être que la portée mais bon
bah enfin j'ai pris train ce matin et on
était quand même beaucoup et en galilée
beaucoup de monde et enfin déjà dans le
train les toutes les restrictions
annoncées
passons car on pas respecté vu que l'on
est côte à côte avec des passagers car
moins d'un mètre
c'est chaud va devoir c'est jean collet
tout mais je pense qu'on n'a pas
vraiment trop chaud à l'heure actuelle
prévoit recommencer a voulu dans les
prochains jours quoi qu'on va vivre au
jour le jour et se posera des questions
après parce que ça devient déjà très
compliquée selon le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand le confinement pourrait
être levée dans une quinzaine de jours à
condition que la propagation du virus
était suffisamment enrayée et on termine
avec ces images positives
d'encouragement qui devrait certainement
faire plaisir au corps médical cinq
minutes d'applaudissements à ce mardi à
20h pour encourager tous les personnels
soignants au premier rang dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie mais celle-ci
populaire lancée un peu partout dans le
pays à paris aux fenêtres et balcons
parce que prêter aux jo non violente
pour mm
la période de confinement cette action a
déjà été vu en espagne et en italie
notamment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû revenir
les systèmes de clips heureux parce que
cela permet de développer de très
grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de tout
petits espaces ce n'est donc pas
surprenant de voir de l'origami dans les
ailes d'insectes et dans les faits